You don’t need to take a trip to the Upside
Down to spot these spooky details in the new
“Stranger Things” trailer.
Freddy Krueger?
Hair metal in another world?
Here are the small details you missed in the
"Stranger Things" 4 volume 1 trailer.
One thing it doesn't take long to notice in
the "Stranger Things" Season 4 trailer is
how much older the main cast appears.
In Season 1, Mike, Eleven, Will, Lucas, and
Dustin were all in the 11-13 range.
And by Season 3 most of them were about 14
years old.
Season 3 debuted almost three years ago at
this point, and the actors playing the kids
are all now young adults.
By now the gang has graduated from attending
Hawkins Middle School to Hawkins High School,
or in Eleven and Will's case, Lenora Hills
High School.
However, not all of them have adjusted well
to the change in schools.
Lucas seems to be doing fine as a member of
the Hawkins basketball team, but Eleven is
still something of a social outcast.
While walking through the school halls, other
students barely acknowledge her, though her
friendship with Will is still strong.
Still, the terrors of high school socialization
will probably be the least of her worries
as shady government organizations, and new
threats from the Upside Down, rear their ugly heads.
"See you on the other side."
"On the other side."
Though looking a little worse for wear, David
Harbour's Jim Hopper is alive after somehow
being transported to Russia after seemingly
dying in the season three finale.
The only question is how Eleven and her friends
will get him back?
Thankfully, the new trailer reveals that rescue
might come with the help of two old friends
that we're pretty sure have no history of
flying airplanes.
In one frenetic clip, Joyce and Hawkins conspiracy
theorist, Murray Bauman, appear layered up
for winter weather in a biplane going through
some major turbulence.
Have they somehow tracked Hopper down and
set off on their own to rescue him from a
Russian gulag?
"Stranger Things" wears its pop culture influences
on its sleeves, and Season 4 will once again
honor the "X-Men."
In the latest trailer, Mike Wheeler and Eddie
Munson can be spotted wearing Hellfire Club
t-shirts, which is a reference to the fictional
society in the "X-Men" comic books whose members
have frequently crossed paths with the heroes
throughout the years.
The Easter egg may have a deeper meaning than
just a nod to the X-Men.
After all, "The Hellfire Club" is also the
name of the premiere episode of Season 4.
Furthermore, a previous trailer hinted at
what could be another group of super-powered children.
Whether that was a flashback to Eleven’s
time in the lab or an indication that there’s
another group of kids getting experimented
on, we’ll just have to wait and see.
Either way, if season four follows up on this,
we may see the return of Eleven's "sister," Kali.
Of course, the "X-Men" influence on "Stranger
Things" has been evident since Season 1.
The very first chapter features a moment where
Will and Dustin discuss "Uncanny X-Men #134"
— the story that introduced Jean Grey's
Dark Phoenix persona.
Eleven’s arc in the show has drawn some
comparisons to Jean Grey in previous seasons;
considering that Dark Phoenix emerges after
a brush with the Hellfire Club in “X-Men,”
fans may want to worry about how Eleven and
the Hellfire Club of “Stranger Things”
will intersect.
Max Mayfield is featured front and center
in this brand new trailer for "Stranger Things."
Introduced in Season 2, Max has a bit of a
tomboy personality and is known for enjoying
video games, cars, and skateboards.
Early in the trailer, we see her talking at
the grave of her brother Billy.
Later, in front of the same grave, we see
Max levitating several feet above the ground
as her friends look on in absolute shock.
The mechanism for her levitation is unknown
at this point, but there is definitely something
supernatural going on.
It could be some manifestation of her brother's
fatal possession in season three, or maybe
Max has inherited some kind of power from
the Upside Down.
Either way, it definitely looks like Max is
in for a wild ride, one that could put her
on even footing with newfound telekinetic
bestie Eleven.
"Him and Lucas are playing Atari right now."
"But friends don't lie."
"But boyfriends lie, all the time."
Toward the end of the action-packed trailer,
there's a blink-and-you'll-miss-it shot of
horror icon Robert Englund with a pretty intense
look.
The star is best known for playing Freddy
Krueger in Wes Craven's "Nightmare on Elm
St." franchise, a supernatural killer who
stalks the dreams of his victims to slaughter
them in various inventive, grisly ways.
Freddie quickly earned his place in horror
history thanks to his unique design, and it's
clear that "Stranger Things" creators, the
Duffer Brothers, are huge fans of the movies.
"There's nothing there.
Dylan stop, you're scaring me."
Englund's brief appearance in the trailer
reveals the first proper look at Victor Creel.
He's a patient at the Pennhurst Mental Hospital
who was committed for murders he perpetrated
back in the 1960s.
He's clearly had a bad time since then because
aside from his bedraggled appearance, his
eyes are heavily scarred, and it looks like
he's probably blind.
It's not clear if Creel's injuries are self-inflicted,
or if they're the result of whatever seems
to be plaguing his ancestral home, the Creel
House.
Either way, it's great to see Englund getting
to play with a creepy new character.
Near the end of the trailer comes a dizzying
sequence of quick cuts, including a few brief
shots of a lone electric guitarist playing
atop a mobile home trailer, while red lightning
flashes in the background.
The long-haired leather-clad musician appears
to be Eddie Munson, one of several new characters
to be introduced in Season 4.
The dim lighting and cold colors suggest that
he may be in the Upside Down, and there are
heavy cables behind him that don't appear
to be necessary for guitar amplification.
Whether he figures into the new season as
a hero or a villain, there’s no easy way
to tell from the trailer.
Since "Stranger Things" debuted, the Hawkins
AV Club has fought the Demogorgon, the Flayed,
and the hulking Mind-Flayer.
But they're about to meet a terrifying new
Big Bad who looks like he's going to be more
than a match for Eleven and the gang.
The trailer delivers its first jump scare
when a creepy monster opens its eyes.
But it's not until the end of the footage
that we get a full look at it.
The gray, fleshy creature is much more human
than the Demogorgon or the Mind-Flayer.
It's highly likely that this unknown villain
is the one providing the narration at the
beginning and end of the trailer, especially
since its full reveal comes with the intimidating line,
"You have lost."
The creature's look is pretty gross, as it
has no nose, and its muscles are stretched
and warped across its entire body.
There are also a number of tentacles protruding
out of its back, and it can clearly use them
to move.
Considering Season 4 is the beginning of the
end, it wouldn't be surprising if this new
evil will stick around for Season 5.
What this new monster has in store for the
kids of Hawkins is unknown.
We'll have to find out when "Stranger Things
4" Vol. 1 arrives on May 27.
"When you say date, just so we're crystal
clear about things..."
"Yeah, Hop?
Stop talking before I change my mind."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Stranger
Things" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.